[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur france 24
consacrait aux tentatives diplomatiques
entre l'est et l'ouest pour reprendre le
langage de la guerre froide au lendemain
des discussions entre russes et
américains c'est au tour de l'otan de
dialoguer avec moscou à bruxelles le
conseil de consultation otan russie
s'est réunie la dernière rencontre sous
ce format remonte à 2019 le chef de
l'otan a constaté des différences
majeures avec moscou mais il est resté
ouvert au dialogue moscou aurait préféré
rester dans un tête à tête avec
washington les échanges se poursuivront
demain jeudi à vienne sur le terrain
vladimir poutine a déployé cent mille
soldats aux frontières de l'ukraine il a
aussi envoyé des troupes au kazakhstan à
la demande du président kazakh après les
émeutes moscou souhaite un retour aux
frontières de 1997 quand l'otan n'avait
pas encore intégré les pays de l'est
comme les pays baltes ou la pologne pays
libéré du joug communiste et qui désirez
entrer dans l'alliance atlantique des
demandes inacceptables pour les
américains et pour les autres membres de
l'otan alors comment les relations se
sont elles en vie mais entre la russie
et l'alliance atlantique quelle est la
stratégie de poutine en europe et ilan
audacieux ou un fin stratège quels sont
les risques de conflits on va en parler
avec mes invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir
à mes côtés gauthier rybinski notre
chroniqueur france24 bonsoir gauthier
soit stéphanie nous avons également par
skype avec nous nicolas tenzer bonsoir
nicolas tenzer professeur à sciences po
et président du cerap bienvenue dans le
débat
également avec nous parce capte toujours
pascal boniface directeur de l'iris et
coauteur avec anne sénéquier de la
géopolitique tout simplement et c'est
aux éditions eyrolles elle ce n'est
qu'hier notre invité hier dans le débat
sur la chine bonsoir pascal boniface
bonsoir et on va retrouver également et
notre correspondant en ukraine gulliver
craag un tout petit peu plus tard avant
de démarrer justement cette discussion
je vais vous proposer je vous propose
d'écouter le secrétaire général de
l'otan l'otan qui a proposé à un
calendrier de réunions sur une série de
dossiers en écoute
ce n'était pas une discussion facile
mais c'est exactement la raison pour
laquelle cette réunion ici importante
les alliés de l'otan sont claires sur
les perspectives de progrès dans les
pourparlers
les alliés expriment leur vive
inquiétude quant au renforcement de
l'armée russe en ukraine et dans ses
environs et appelle la russie à
désamorcer immédiatement la situation et
à respecter la souveraineté et
l'intégrité territoriale de ses voisins
de
respecter l'intégrité territoriale de
ses voisins pascal boniface pour faire
un peu d'histoire et cadres est
justement ce débat en décembre 1991
l'union soviétique s'effondre le pacte
de varsovie qui réunit les pays de l'est
satellite de l'union soviétique
disparaît et en face vous avez l'otan
l'alliance politico-militaires au tour
des états unis certains pays de l'est
comme la pologne et les pays baltes et
la hongrie veulent y adhérer il entre
dans l'otan effectivement
1997 en juillet 1997 1997 c'est donc
l'acte fondateur qui régit la relation
entre l'otan l'otan qui s'engagent en
même temps à ne pas envoyer d'armes
nucléaires dans les nouveaux pays
membres donc finalement on voit qu'il y
avait un deal avec la russie à l'époque
l'otan n'a pas toujours il est perçu
comme le diable par la russie
non surtout à cette époque boris elstine
n'a aucun moyen de s'opposer à l'otan
parce que la russie un état de
déliquescence totale
le pib a chuté de moitié entre 91 et
2000 est en fait brice estinnes subi les
événements et donc qu'il ne peut se pose
à rien au début les américains notamment
bill tilden étaient réticents à élargir
nos temps parce que ils pensaient que
les américains avaient trop de
responsabilités il fallait plutôt les
limiter mais les pays et notamment la
pologne notamment les pays baltes eux
est très très demandeur d'une adhésion
parce que il avait une peur
existentielle de la russie la russie
n'était plus lours mais l'histoire est
longue pour ces pays et donc ils veulent
une protection et il concède par
ailleurs que l'europe qui avait échoué
il faut bien le dire par rapport au
conflit yougoslave ne donnait pas une
garantie suffisante et que seuls les
états unis avaient les muscles la force
pour garantir leur sécurité par rapport
à la menace qu'ils estiment être la
menace russe et puis clinton a changé
d'avis avant les élections de 96 parce
que les électeurs américains d'origine
polonaise
on fait pression et donc il a changé
effectivement l'otan s'est élargi et là
il ya deux discours qui ne se recoupent
pas pour les pays de l'otan c'est une
alliance défensive et donc chacun est
libre d'y adhérer la russie ne peut pas
avoir un veto sur l'adhésion et le
discours us c'est de dire que l'otan
l'encerclent de plus en plus et que la
guerre du kosovo de 99 montre qu'elle
pousse se lancer dans des guerres sans
avoir été attaquées et donc il ya deux
discours complètement parallèle qui se
ne se parlent plus notamment depuis
l'arrivée de poutine au pouvoir parce
que pour poutine a pour idée fixe de
restaurer la grandeur de la russie et
ses déclarations c'est que l'erreur de
la russie d'avoir fait confiance dans
les occidentaux il y aura des
occidentaux d'avoir pris cette confiance
pour de la faible c'est donc
effectivement ce qui était possible du
temps du déliquescent elstine ne l'est
pas du temps de l'alfa mal poutine il
revient donc à
7997 donc avant justement l'entrée de
ces états dans l'otan nicolas tenzer
poutine donc dénonce l'unilatéralisme
américain à partir de 2007 et il
présente l'otan comme une menace en 2008
l'otan propose à l'ukraine et à la
biélorussie de rejoindre l'alliance ou
la puce ion de george deubeuliou bush
est ce que c'est cette ligne rouge qui
est franchie pour poutine et qui fait
que justement il va interpréter l'otan
comme une vraie menace
alors je crois qu'il ya d'abord deux
choses d'abord de pouvoir que tout au
début de son mandat poutine n'était pas
du tout apparemment en tout cas dans son
discours complètement hostile a le temps
mais très vite il s'est aperçu que en
fait pour affirmer son pouvoir il lui
était totalement nécessaire d'essayer de
remettre en quelque sorte la main sur
les territoires qu'ils avaient perdue
alors il n'a pas fait immédiatement il
ya eu évidemment la première chose a été
la géorgie en 2008 avec 20 % du
territoire qui ont été en quelque sorte
saisie et qu'ils sont toujours
d'ailleurs par la russie
et puis il ya eu ces offensives de plus
en plus forte ce discours de plus en
plus martial marquer évidemment par
l'invasion
l'ukraine en 2014 et l'annexion illégale
de la crimée et poutine a en quelque
sorte continuer pour une raison
d'ailleurs très simple c'est qu'il s'est
aperçu qu'il n'y avait pas d' abord pas
d'encerclement l'otan parce que quand on
regarde les forces russes et celles de
l'otan on a quand même une disproportion
au profit des forces russes mais surtout
et kleber grosso modo c'est quoi
quelques centaines de troupes côté
occidental côté autant et enfin quel
quelques milliers et puis eux nettement
nettement plus je dirais du côté du côté
de l'as du côté de la russie et puis
surtout encore une fois on s'aperçoit
que l'otan n'a jamais agressé personne
et je pense que c'est tout à fait exact
de dire que le temps est une alliance ex
anciennement défensive alors que
effectivement il ya eu ces offensives
multiples de la part de poutine qui se
sont encore accélérées au cours
évidemment de la période qui a suivi
l'invasion de l'ukraine avec la guerre
qui n'a jamais cessé en ukraine il faut
le rappeler à la guerre existe toujours
l'ukraine est déjà envahi avoir
peut-être une nouvelle invasion encore
plus forte mais elle est déjà envahi
plus encore récemment ces derniers jours
on l'a vu kazakhstan avec une volonté de
plus en plus affirmé clairement par
comptines dans ses discours qui est une
volonté d'établir ou de rétablir en
quelque sorte une zone d' influence dans
les pays qui lui ont échappé y compris
les anciens pays de l'ex urss comme les
états balle est en quelque sorte
d'empêcher les peuples d'affirmer leur
volonté d'indépendance et y compris
évidemment dans le choix des alliances
que ce soit d'ailleurs l'otan ou de
l'union européenne
et voilà où nous en sommes aujourd'hui
et on va l'oublier il a encore une fois
il a gagné jusqu'à présent il a toujours
gagné parce qu'il a pas eu d'opposition
alors un poutine est accusée gauthier
les occidentaux d'avoir travaillé leur
promesse de ne jamais s'étendra laisse
d'abord est-ce que c'est faux et est ce
que les occidentaux tout de même commis
des erreurs est ce qu'ils ont nourri ce
sentiment d'humiliation des russes
contestable mans et ça n'exclut en rien
le comportement du pouvoir russe
aujourd'hui mais au delà de 2 ce qu'ont
dit nos invités et qui est tout à fait
exact il y à une humiliation
supplémentaire qui s'est produit dans
ces années
1990 2000 c'est l'invasion de la russie
par l'argent roi par les capitaux avec
une humiliation terrible aussi du peuple
russe de ceux qui n'en profitent pas
c'est l'époque aussi où vous avez des
citoyens russes qui en quelques semaines
se bâtissent en jouant avec la bourse de
moscou se bâtissent des fortunes
absolument insolente et ça pour vladimir
poutine ce n'est pas parce qu'ils
s'occupent du sort des plus pauvres
s'est pas là le problème c'est que son
objectif qui est de recréer la grandeur
de la russie quand ils regrettent l'urss
c'est pas le système communiste
forcément qu'il le regrette mais c'est
la magnificence de la russie et bien
quand ils considèrent cela il dit oui
c'est une humiliation
et c'est en ce sens que l'occident nous
humilient c'est vrai qu'on peut
considérer que l'occident avait promis
de ne pas élargir l'otan mais
probablement promesses ou c'était
quelque chose d'anormal normal
normalement ça vire ce nom en principe
c'est quelque chose qui a été proposé
par par george bush le premier job to
bush qui avait annoncé que pour prix de
l'acceptation par moscou de la
réunification de l'allemagne elle m'a il
n'y aurait pas d les rejets
d'élargissement de l'otan aux pays dits
satellite et c'est vrai qu'ensuite la
pologne qui de par son histoire de trois
partages et les pays baltes qui ont qui
ont vécu ce jour us pendant pendant
presque 70 ans et même avant eh bien on
dit non ça n'est pas possible on veut
pouvoir adhérer à l'otan mais cette
humiliation au delà si vous voulez de ce
malentendu appelons le comme ça de ce
malentendu diplomatique il y à cette
humiliation très forte le seul problème
c'est quand même une revanche à prendre
de la part de poutine tout à fait le
problème se termine d'une phrase c'est
combien de temps poutine va t'il encore
servir cet argument usé jusqu'à la corde
qui est en fait un cache misère de sa
politique interne à laurier la
problématique de l'ukraine va trouver
justement en ukraine gulliver crack
notre correspondante l'univers bonsoir
poutine a envoyé à cent mille soldats à
la frontière de l'ukraine on le sait les
ukrainiens ont également renforcé leur
armement ils ont acheté des brawn turcs
ils reçoivent d'ailleurs l'aide des
états unis et le président zelensky
l'actuel président arnaud est un peu
avec la tradition des parades militaires
est ce qu'il redoute véritablement une
intervention militaire notamment
aériennes de moscou
je pense qu'en tout cas il se prépare
l'ukraine ne cesse de demander de l'aide
militaire de ses alliés on appris hier
que les états unis avaient déboursé 200
millions de dollars supplémentaires et
l'ukraine depuis le début de la guerre
en 2014 consacrent plus de 4% de son pib
à la défense chaque année donc bien sûr
il y à des préparations mais vous voyez
peut-être je vous parle depuis une
station de ski la saison des sports
d'hiver bat son plein en ukraine le
président volodymyr zelensky lui-même
étaient ici il y a quelques jours je
pense qu'il ya une volonté là de montrer
la défiance de montrer le on n'a pas
peur ça c'est la façade que les
ukrainiens veulent montrer au monde mais
c'est aussi pour beaucoup d'entre eux en
tout cas ceux à qui j'ai parlé la vérité
beaucoup d'ukrainiens peine vraiment à
croire que vladimir poutine prendrait un
tel pas à la limite ils ont plus peur
que les occidentaux cède à ce qu'il
considère ce bluff de la russie que ce
que la russie procède réellement à une
intervention militaire d'envergure mais
bien sûr qu'on tourne à 100 mille
soldats et tout cet équipement un
militaire a amassé juste de l'autre côté
de sa frontière il est difficile d'être
complètement complètement tranquille et
il ya des préparatifs aussi au niveau de
la population civile et la mairie de
kiev par exemple a établi une carte des
endroits de la ville pouvant servir
d'abris en cas de bombardement aérien de
la ville il y a aussi un appel à
rejoindre
ddd groupe de défense territoriale des
unités des défenses et territoriales un
sondage intéressante a été publiée par
l'institut de kiev de sociologie en
décembre on a vu qu'un tiers des
interrogés ont dit qu'ils étaient prêts
à défendre leur pays ou leur ville
plutôt la question posée sait s'il y
avait du combat dont votre ville ou
votre village est ce que vous serez prêt
à défendre les armes à la main et un
tiers des interrogés ont dit que oui les
armes à la main et puis 20%
supplémentaires on t'y pas les armes à
la main mais certainement je voudrais
faire ce que je peux pour défendre
l'ukraine donc ouais selon les sondages
en tout cas les ukrainiens ont plutôt un
esprit défiance sont prêts à défendre
leur pays ça c'est aussi le message
qu'on a reçu mais c'est peut-être
prévisible quand on a parlé aux soldats
dont le dôme basse en décembre bien sûr
ils disent qu'ils sont prêts à défendre
leur ville à défendre et infliger un
maximum de pertes ou rue si jamais il y
avait une incursion merci gulliver donc
gulliver craquant diact d'ukraine pascal
boniface est ce que poutine montre les
muscles pour imposer son agenda à ce
qu'il bluffe ou est ce qui effectivement
pour aller au bout d'une intervention
militaire en ukraine alors d'une pin
pour revenir sur ce cas dit vaucresson
c'est certain que si poutine empêcher la
crimée a perdu l'ukraine l'ukraine était
auparavant partagée entre des courants
pro cela avait des courants pro
occidentaux toute mise à part dans le
combat ce qui est toujours partagé le
reste du pays est devenu vigoureusement
pro occidental et vigoureusement
antirusse donc le sentiment national
ukrainien est désormais antivirus est ce
que boot inn bluff oui je très
honnêtement depuis le temps qu'on parle
d'une nouvelle agression militaire bien
sûr il a semblé de soldats ils sont pas
tous à la frontière certains sont un peu
plus loin mais je ne crois pas que
poutine aient envie de s'embarrasser que
dans base des dans un bourbier il a eu
le bourbier afghan il bourbier
tchétchène et poutine sait très bien que
la rue sirey le plus grand mal à gérer
le dombass la clim et c'était simple il
y avait d'une part eu une historicité
différentes et la population était
largement pro russe le dombass est
beaucoup plus mélanger donc au delà des
menaces de sanctions économiques ou de
riposte militaire petite faim plutôt
monter les enchères parce qu'il a obtenu
ce qu'il voulait ça fait des mois
insiste des années qu il dit qu'il veut
être traité d'égal à égal par les
américains sur les questions de sécurité
européenne et l'a finalement il a eu son
sommet avec baden deux d'ailleurs et
puis il ya des négociations bilatérales
russo américaines et donc effectivement
hilal dans une inde où je mens
relativement classique d'ailleurs montré
ses muscles pour ne pas s'en servir et
obtenir un bénéfice politique nicolas
tenzer à ce que les états unis
interviendrait militairement pour les
ukrainiens s'il y avait une attaque
russe
je crois que dans les circonstances
actuelles non et c'est bien je dirais
l'inquiétude que l'on peut avoir et je
sais que poutine le sait assez nettement
parce que joe biden a déclaré qu'il en
avait assez des gars éternel c'était
après le retrait des troupes américaines
d'afghanistan
on le voit sur une position de
négociation
il est très prudent ou même sur la
livraison d'armes létales d'appui de
renseignement de surveillance aérienne à
l'ukraine et de ce point de vue là
poutine est en position de force parce
que effectivement parce qu'elle l'a
rappelé tout à l'heure il a obtenu d'une
certaine manière ce qu'il voulait et je
crois qu'en fait ce qu'ils cherchent à
faire et je crains parfois que les
américains ne tombent dans le piège ce
serait de dire finalement vous voyez je
n'en voyais pas l'ukraine est donc
maintenant vous me donnez des
concessions et je pense que de ce point
de vue là il aura en quelque sorte gagné
si ça se passe ainsi parce que il
conservera son emprise très forte dans
bas ce qui conduit à une situation gelé
il conservera la crimée il continuera à
pouvoir intervenir un peu partout dans
le monde y compris pour commettre des
crimes de guerre comme en syrie voilà et
je pense que c'est une position vraiment
de force précisément parce que les
autres ne la montre pas suffisamment
c'est ce que croit dans cette espèce des
taux que nous sommes aujourd'hui alors
que encore une fois je crois qu'il faut
vraiment leur rappeler depuis 22 ans
qu'il est au pouvoir poutine a toujours
d'une certaine manière gagner la guerre
il a toujours obtenu ce qu'il voulait je
disais voilà 20% de la géorgie sont
toujours préoccupés
voilà l'ukraine est aussi en grande
partie occupé la majeure partie non une
grande partie du double crime et il a
des positions très fortes en séries on
voit le déployer ses troupes avec wagner
notamment en afrique et soutient le
régime de maduro venezuela on a vu son
intervention en quelque sorte au
kazakhstan qui est en train de retomber
en cours il est tout à fait prête à vous
entendre à la pana oui pardon il est
tous azimuts poutine à vous écouter un
animal est par ailleurs effectivement le
peuple le peuple crève de faim la grande
pauvreté augmente l'épidémie que 8,19 a
été gérée d'une manière h moins atroces
en russie avec vraisemblablement plus de
800 mille neuf cent mille morts ce qui
est absolument terrible les
infrastructures sont dans un état
désastreux il a en quelque sorte
sacrifier son peuple le malheur de son
peuple pour ses ambitions militaires et
de grandes puissances c'est à dire tu as
20 ans 20 36 la russie sera et ça on le
sait depuis longtemps s'il n'ya pas de
changement économique et poutine n'en
veut pas condamner un déclin en quelque
sorte qui rit médias gauthier est ce que
vous êtes d'accord à ce que vient de
dire ni par hasard est ce qu'un petit
neveu refaire une sorte de yalta une
sorte de deux congrès de vienne en
sentant que les états unis regardent
plutôt vers l'asie mais est ce que il ya
quand même des limites la pologne et les
pays baltes vont rester dans l'otan lui
parle de 1997 mais à aucun moment la
pologne les pays baltes ou la hongrie ne
quitterait l'otan ça ça ne serait pas
acceptée du côté des occidentaux alors
justement pour répondre à l'une des
questions que vous avez placée en
exergue de ce débat c'est à dire est ce
que c'est un stratège moi je ne pense
pas que poutine souhaite un fin stratège
je pense que c'est un excellent
tacticien et que aujourd'hui c'est
peut-être le correctif que j'apporte à
ce que nos invités ont dit je ne suis
pas persuadé qu'il soit en position de
force avec cette affaire'' ukrainienne à
quoi réagit-il au fond certes il a eu la
crimée certes il a essayé d'introduire
dans le régime ukrainien des éléments
pro russe mais ça n'a pas marché
aujourd'hui dans la constitution
ukrainienne il est stipulé que le pays
veut adhérer à l'otan bien
le donne basse on en a parlé c'est
plutôt quelque chose qui pourrait être
potentiellement gênant pour lui que
profitable et donc moi je le sens comme
étant quelqu'un quitte en comment
dirais-je en panne d'outils ou de levier
sur la scène internationale et que cette
crise ukrainienne est une façon pour lui
de dire retenez moi ou je fais un
malheur c'est à dire en peu chez moi
d'intervenir en ukraine en me donnant de
nouvelles de nouveaux outils de
nouvelles bis comme on dit vulgairement
pour être puissants sur le domaine
international parce que pour le reste
cette affaire ukrainienne pour lui ne se
solde pas par quelque chose de très
bénéfique jusqu'à présent et quelles
concessions pourraient faire justement
les états unis alors cette histoire de
l'otan est ce qu'il pourrait dire
justement mon l'ukraine ne ne partait
sera plus alors c'est sympa parce pardon
ne participera pas à l'otan ça peut être
ça met alors à ce moment-là ça
ressemblerait aux accords pardonnez-moi
la comparaison mais au protocole secret
de du pacte germano soviétique où un
certain nombre de choses ne sont pas
dites alors ça pourrait être ça mais ça
peut être aussi quelque chose comme une
une adhésion de l'ukraine qui ne serait
pas une intégration là il faudrait jouer
sur les mots et sur les dispositifs
militaires ça peut être ça ou alors on
peut s'entendre éventuellement sur une
finalisation de l'ukraine vous savez
c'est à dire ni à l'est ni à l'ouest
mais le problème de fond c'est ce que je
viens de dire c'est que la population
ukrainienne comme l'a dit pascal
boniface partout de ces manoeuvres
essais menés a été propulsée vers le
camp occidental ou delà même des régions
qui étaient traditionnellement pro
occidental ce n'est pas le cas du
kazakhstan kazakhstan la russie est
intervenue à la demande du président
kazakh après les émeutes de la semaine
dernière les troupes sont toujours sur
place d'ailleurs à les troupes de russes
et puis des alliés de la russie on
retrouve elena volochine justement
almaty elena bonsoir almaty c'est la
capitale économique du kazakhstan cette
intervention russe elena n'est ce pas
pour montrer que les anciens satellites
de l'urss de l'union soviétique reste la
chasse gardée de moscou
je ne pense pas qu'on soit exactement
dans ce cas de figure là puisque il faut
le rappeler s'est cassé une jambe marque
tokayev qui face à une situation qu'il
ne contrôlait absolument plus s'est mis
d'accord pas officiellement
officiellement il a appelé à l'aide mais
on sait qu'il s'est mis d'accord avec le
kremlin pour faire appel aux forces de
l'organisation du traité de sécurité
collective cette organisation militaire
régionale menée par la russie donc ce
n'était pas une initiative au départ de
moscou d'intervenir militairement au
kazakhstan pour garder son ancien c'est
évident c'était bel et bien venir en
aide à un président qui perdait qu'ils
risquaient de perdre le contrôle de la
situation
les forces ont réussi leur mission selon
tokayev et aussi parce que tout
simplement il n'y a plus aucun mouvement
de contestation aujourd'hui pour le
moment en tout cas au kazakhstan elles
vont se retirer demain ce qu'on peut
noter c'est que peut-être il s'agit d'un
virage dans le giron russe de la part du
kazakhstan puisque rappelons que le
prédécesseur de casser le jeu mart
akaïev le tout puissant président ancien
président du kazakhstan noursoultan
nazarbaïev qui a dirigé le pays pendant
30 ans qui est devenue depuis ce qu'il
se fût il se fait appeler le leader de
la nation le leader spirituel le lance
l'homme fort du pays a jusqu'à présent
jusqu'à ces mouvements de contestation
et bien lui il affichait clairement une
volonté d'indépendance vis-à-vis du
grand voisin russe de partenariat certes
avec l'union douanière notamment des
relations tout à fait cordiale et de
coopération mais il a toujours affiché
sa volonté et sa velléité d'avoir le
kazakhstan en tant que puissance
régionale qui regardait aussi bien en
orient qu'en occident alors cet appel à
la 17 entrée de troupes russes sur le
territoire du kazakhstan c'est une
première dans l'histoire indépendants du
pays depuis la chute de l'urss et en
cela ce n'est peut-être pas le seul
signe de rupture et de là est la seule
le seul symbole du fait que casser
ingmar tokayev est en train de rompre
avec le système de son prédécesseur
noursoultan nazarbaïev avec peut-être
effectivement ce tournant dans le giron
de la russie parce qu'elle me remercient
elena et elena donc en direct d'almaty
au kazakhstan pascal boniface justement
ce président kazakh qui demandent à la
russie d'intervenir on sait aussi que
vladimir poutine a soutenu lukashenko en
biélorussie au moment justement de la
révolte populaire est ce que ça fait
partie tout de même la redéfinition la
sécurité de la russie c'est à dire la
russie un peu comme pivot de la sécurité
dans la région contre finalement les
révoltes des peuples oui enfin très
clairement moscou ne veut pas que le
kazakhstan que la biélorussie et que
l'ukraine ne sortent de leurs orbites et
encore moins adhèrent à des ordinations
occidental le kazakhstan c'est
extrêmement important pour la russie
puisque il ya là quand même la base de
baikonur qui est là c'est le pays le
plus riche de la région son pib
l'équivalent de l'ensemble des autres
pib de la région aura d autres pays en
ce temps et est donc poutine n'a aucune
envie que de kahrizak sion tombe de
l'autre côté alors en même temps
contrairement à ce qui s'est passé en
biélorussie et contrairement à ce qui
s'est passé en ukraine il y a pas
vraiment trop d'opposition à
l'intervention russe au kazakhstan parce
que les compagnies occidentales
pétrolière ils sont établies elles n'ont
pas envie que les ordres ci organise la
chine bien sûr soutien parce qu'elle n'a
pas envie que la minorité ouïgoure lève
la tête et ils protestent et donc
l'intervention kazakhstan a suscité
moins de réactions négatives y compris
les occidentaux que ce qui se passe sur
le possible en ukraine que ce qui s'est
passé en biélorussie mais il est certain
que pour moscou le kazakhstan fait
partie de sa sphère d influence nicolas
tenzer ça veut dire effectivement que ça
reste la chasse gardée quoi qu'il arrive
de la russie ces pays anciennement
satellite
oui effectivement c'est à dire qu'il y a
une volonté et ça a été annoncée
plusieurs fois par routine de rétablir
des zones d'affluence est une notion qui
normalement a été totalement bannie à la
fin de la seconde guerre mondiale à les
traiter de l'onu etc et surtout se
claque la traduction concrète de cela
c'est quand même l'oppression des
peuples je dirais qu'une certaine coûte
bannière poutine a probablement plus
peur d'avoir autour de lui des régimes
démocratiques que ce soit en ukraine que
ce soit au bélarus où ailleurs que
l'entrée de ces pays pour certains dans
l'otan pour d'autres éventuellement
d'ailleurs dans l'union européenne on le
voit avec également la moldavie qui est
maintenant un état totalement
démocratique mais avec l'enclavé en
quelque sorte aux russes de la
transnistrie enfin sous contrôle russe
horus d'ailleurs et puis on voit aussi
qu'il ya une extension de la sphère
d'influencé au nom de l' on pourrait
dire la sla vite et si je puis dire avec
vous voyez ce qui se passe actuellement
et en serbie mais aussi en bosnie
herzégovine et spécifiquement dans la
république asper ce cas où vous avez une
sorte de nouveau nationalisme fortement
attisée par la russie qui est en train
de se déployer c'est à dire que là aussi
la grande peur de poutine c'est de voir
que des peuples pourrez choisir la voie
européenne la voix de l'occident et la
voie de la liberté et ça c'est
totalement
intolérables en quelque sorte pour ce
régime maintenant peut-être un dernier
point quand même sur la question de
l'ukraine aujourd'hui je pense qu'il
n'est absolument pas possible que de
manière officielle les alliés renoncent
à cette politique de la porte ouverte
qui est défini dans le traité 10
l'article 10 du traité de l'otan je
crois que c'est un principe d'
absolument fondamental on voit
d'ailleurs la finlande et la suède qui
pourrait peut-être avec beaucoup de 2,2
conditionnelle quand même rejoindre
l'organisation de washington afin de
diriger par le traité de washington je
crois que l'on voit qu'il y a quand même
une volonté des peuples et des pays de
se défendre parce que cette menace et
les quand même réel et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui nous ne pouvons pas et
l'otan ne le fera jamais refusé la
perspective pour ces pays quel qu'il
soit s'ils le souhaitent de rejoindre un
jour le temps parce que tout simplement
leur défense repose malgré tout là
dessus mais ça veut dire qu'on reste
dans le même rapport de force gauthier
si les négociations patinent et pour le
moment franchement on va pas dire que
c'est vraiment avancé quels sont les
risques quels sont les scénarii
possibles d'abord un risque de guerre on
l'exclût ou pas donc pas totalement
ce que je disais tout à l'heure sur
l'absence de d'outils dont la dans la
boîte à outils de poutine s'il n'obtient
pas satisfaction de ce point de vue ou
bien s'il n'obtient pas des
gratifications symbolique ça veut dire
on parlait tout à l'heure du fait qu'il
a lu un sommet avec baden qui pourrait y
avoir d'autres choses qui montrent qu'il
a repris pied sur le haut de la scène
internationale à ce moment-là l'escale
année toujours possible il ne faut pas
l'exclure mais probablement qu'il y a ce
putin aujourd'hui plus la volonté de
faire peur que d'intervenir
militairement et ça n'exclut absolument
pas les pratiques russe parce que on
parle du militaire là mais la pratique
russe culturel au sens le plus large du
terme qui consiste par exemple à
investir des domaines politiques des
pays européens quitte à soutenir des
candidats d'extrême droite ça ça n'est
pas un ministre non plus et là aussi il
ya eu une influence russe donc ça
n'exclut pas une intervention militaire
mais c'est quelque chose qui dans
l'esprit me semble-t-il de vladimir
poutine serait un recours ultime et
signifierait qu'il a totalement échoué
dans sa tentative de récupérer des
outils qui lui permettent d'avoir une
forme de levier sur l'actualité
internationale pascal boniface vous êtes
d'accord si les négociations patinent
quelle sera l'issue à ce qu'est un
risque effectivement de guerre et si non
quelles sont les scénarii possibles
alors bien sûr le risque d' air ne peut
jamais être écartée parce qu'il faut s'y
préparer ne serait-ce que si on veut
l'éviter mais je ne crois pas que ça
soit le scénario majeur ni même qu'il ya
une chance réelle que cela en porte bien
il peut y avoir plusieurs solutions ip
your le statu quo mais en même temps
poutine ne pourra pas maintenir cent
mille soldats trop proche de la
frontière ukrainienne ça coûte cher que
il faut qu'il y ait des pas autrement
donc il faut trouver le moyen en fait
comme toujours en diplomatie si l'on
veut un accord il faut que personne ne
perde la face trouver un accord où ni
les russes ni américain mais pas non
plus les ukrainiens et européens ne
perde la face donc il peut y avoir des
engagements il peut y avoir un
engagement quel type d'engagement pascal
boniface concrètement est ce qu'ils
peuvent dire aux ukrainiens les
américains et les alliés de l'otan en
fait vous ne rentrerai pas dans l'otan
donc non parce que il se serait donné un
droit de veto à poutine sur l'otan et ça
serait un discrédit et donc
politiquement stratégiquement les
américains et l'otan ne peut pas se
permettre mais entre dire que l'ukraine
ne rentrera jamais dans l'otan et faire
que la situation se poursuit puisque
finalement l'ukraine a le droit d'entrer
dans l'otan depuis 2008 elle n'y est
toujours pas et la france cela n'est
toujours pas pourquoi pascal boniface
parce que les clauses non acceptes tu ne
votes pas en sa faveur oui enfin disons
qu'il ya les billets qui sont favorables
comme la pologne les pays bas âge mais
la france et l'allemagne sont très
défavorable parce que si poutine est
très réticent à mettre en place les
accords de minsk on ne peut pas dire que
les ukrainiens se soient précipités pour
le faire puisque dès le départ il
considère que ces accords leur sont
défavorables et qu'ils ont été signé
sous la contrainte donc aussi il
faudrait peut-être temps en temps faire
pression sur l'ukraine pour qu'elle
mette un peu plus activement en oeuvre
les accords de minsk mais donc on peut
très bien avoir
une situation où l'ukraine n'entrez pas
dans l'otan on ne dit pas formellement
vous ne serez pas dans le temps mais
c'est le statu quo laon l'aube l'ukraine
a le droit d'adhérer à l'otan mais du
fait des réticences de certains pays
européens et du fait que les américains
essayent peut-être de calmer un peu le
jeu il ne rentre pas c'est ce qui se
passe depuis 2008 mais justement nicolas
tenzer si effectivement il ya de cette
espèce de statu quo est ce que vladimir
poutine retirera ses troupes de la
frontière
mais c'est à dire qu'il y aura d'abord
encore une fois des menaces permanentes
évidemment de la part du régime russe
ensuite il faut vraiment leur rappeler
les troupes russes sont déjà dans une
partie du dong bassin dans une partie du
donesk et de lougansk sans parler de la
crim est occupé donc elles sont déjà là
c'est à dire qu'on a une situation gelée
se rappelle quand même que l'année
dernière vous avez eu 77 soldats
ukrainiens qui ont été tués donc la
guerre elle existe à trois heures de
paris je crois qu'il faut quand même
avoir ça en tête ensuite vous savez qui
est des prisons dans le dôme basten eu
effectivement par les forces spéciales
russes où l'on torture régulièrement on
pourrait parler en crimée également des
persécutions contre les tatars qui sont
aussi absolument abominable
donc je dirais si l'europe tient quand
même un tout petit peu à ses principes
et à ses valeurs c'est quelque chose qui
ne peut pas accepter puis ça a été très
justement rappelé tout à l'heure il y a
aussi toutes les attaques hybrides
contre les régimes démocratiques en
europe avec des stratégies d'influencé
des stratégies de corruption aussi d'un
certain nombre de personnes et je dirais
qu'il est aujourd'hui il est quand même
temps aussi de riposter c'est à dire que
jusqu'à présent on a été sur une absence
totale de riposte devant ces menaces
pour la plupart des pays européens voire
en partie des états unis aujourd'hui
c'est quand même une situation gelée de
menace permanente une sorte d'épée de
damoclès sur notre tête on absolument
pas accepter et donc la question n'est
pas de savoir si l'ukraine demain ou
après demain on va rentrer dans le temps
la question c'est comment est ce que
l'on met fin à cette situation de menace
permanente et encore une fois qui est un
de ces temps que j'évoquais les balkans
tout à l'heure et je crois que ça va
être un point particulièrement chaud
surtout qu'un certain nombre de ces pays
balkans ont quand même une perspective
certains sont candidats d'entrer dans
l'union européenne est aujourd'hui
poutine ferme totalement par ces actions
cette voie et par le soutien ou s'il ya
des mouvements d'extrême droite ou
nationalistes et ça je crois que c'est
ça le défi aujourd'hui n'est de
auxquelles nous devons répondre et est
ce que l'europe veut vraiment se
présenter comme puissance il l'entend
comme ça a été affirmée complet par le
président de la république et par un
certain nombre d'autres leaders
européens ça suppose effectivement de
s'opposer de manière tout à fait nette à
toutes ces actions ah oui mais alors
justement justement gauthier l'europe
dont parle nicolas tenzer ce n'est pas
une grande puissance on voit bien
qu'elle est absente des discussions que
même le d'ailleurs le président
ukrainien qui demandait lui a participé
aussi n'y participent pas effectivement
la france et l'allemagne ne souhaite pas
vraiment que l'ukraine rentrer dans
l'otan donc il n'ya pas une europe
puissante qui vraiment négocier
aujourd'hui avec poutine alors il ya
deux choses lorsque vous venez de dire
il ya à la fois le fait que la france et
l'allemagne comme ça à été rappelés sont
opposés en tout cas fortement réticente
à l'idée d'une entrée de l'ukraine dans
l'otan seulement comme cela était rare
et appelé également les deux que ce soit
la france ou l'allemagne se rendent
compte que en échange on va dire de leur
disons modération face à l'ukraine dans
l'otan ils n'obtiennent pas grand-chose
contenu des interventions hybride de la
russie et compte tenu aussi de la mise à
l'écart de l'europe et ce en janvier au
deuxième point c'est que quand qu'il
devrait venir être plus ferme et devrait
plus faire ça ne changerait pas
forcément quelque chose mais quand vous
voyez que l'idée principale par rapport
à l'europe de vladimir poutine ces
deux-là démonétisé politiquement c'est
de prouver qu'elle n'a aucune utilité
comment prouver sa d'une meilleure façon
qu'aujourd'hui en simplement en ignorant
l'europe en disant je veux bien sûr je
parle aux états unis à la rigueur je
veux bien parler avec l'otan mais avec
ces nains politiques que sont les
européens il n'en est pas question donc
là ça c'est ce que poutine bien sûr mais
la complexité pour l'europe alors ça
vous le savez c'est la quadrature du
cercle comment être politiquement unie
quand desdites des régimes au sein de
l'europe sont si différents
politiquement et la c éternel problème
de l'europe c'est comment trouver une
parole simple d'une part sur le plan
politique à cause de ce que je viens de
dire et d'autre part sur le plan tout
simplement militaire alors que
l'arlésienne européenne c'est
précisément de créer une forme on
appelle ça autonomie stratégique mais de
défense européenne et ça c'est très très
lointain pascal boniface on peut dire
que quand même elle brille par son
absence l'europe pendant ces
négociations vladimir poutine n'a pas
souhaité ils voulaient de même négocié
uniquement avec les états unis a
finalement accepté une négociation avec
avec l'otan il n'y a pas d'europe
puissante là encore face non mais c'est
pas seulement de la part effectivement
ça a été dit c'est que poutine considère
que l'europe est alignée sur les états
unis et qui n'a rien obtenir des pays
européens et donc ils s'adressent
directement au patron de l'alliance que
son essai ni parce qu'ils pensent que
seuls les signes peuvent lui donner
quelque chose et les états unis n'ont
pas fait des pieds et des mains pour
dire ça se passe en europe il faut que
l'europe soit présente ils sont
chrétiens peuvent aussi quand même avoir
un sentiment un petit peu curieux
puisque l'on parle d'eux sans qu'il soit
là donc effectivement là c'est quand
même relativement on les passait quand
même d'une situation où la france et
l'allemagne avaient parrainé l'accord de
minsk où il y avait le président
ukrainien le président russe prochaine
quoi l'époque poutine déjà qui avait
permis au moins de freiner le conflit et
d'avancer un petit peu même si ces
accords n'ont pas été mises en oeuvre ou
mois il avait évité une guerre de grande
ampleur et la france et l'allemagne est
au coeur du dispositif aujourd'hui elles
sont marginalisées donc c'est peut-être
quand même une source de réflexion au
moment où s'ouvre la présidence
française du conseil de l'union
européenne et comment l'expliqué nicolas
tenzer qu'elle soit si marginaliser ces
puissances européennes la france
l'allemagne mais je retiens il ya deux
facteurs il ya un premier facteur qui
est tout simplement l'absence de moyens
militaires suffisants pour pouvoir
s'opposer à ces agressions c'est à dire
qu' il n'y a rien qui soit l'équivalent
au sein de l'union européenne de laïcs
lson mais c'était déjà le cas du temps
des accords dominé les
messins encore une fois c'est une c'est
une permanence c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui d'ailleurs tous les
accords de minsk si la france et
l'allemagne ont finalement été très
allants sur ces accords et si c'était
d'une certaine manière à l'époque
peut-être la moins mauvaise solution
c'est aussi parce que les états unis ne
voulait pas intervenir dans le conflit
dans le conflit ukrainien maintenant
effectivement c'est accor domine c'est
un désastre absolu pour l'ukraine
comment imaginer par exemple des
élections libres dans le donbass sous un
contrôle russe enfin il ya bien d'autres
questions de ce genre voilà et
deuxièmement c'est que l'europe est
quand même profondément divisé vous avez
un certain nombre de pays qui cherche
qui croient toujours de manière à mon
sens très naïve que l'on peut négocier
quelque chose avec vladimir poutine
d'autres qui sont sur une ligne dure
notamment la 1e ou les états baltes
voilà et cette division là elle
s'aperçoit regardez par exemple le rejet
de la proposition allemande tenu par la
france et par l'autriche en juin dernier
d'un sommet entre l'union européenne et
la russie c'est quelque chose qui paraît
tout à fait inacceptable parce
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a rien à négocier
et donc c'est une à une division très
profonde de l'europe ya pas de stratégie
commune il n'y a pas de voie commune sur
cette question donc c'est ça qui à mon
avis constitue l'obstacle principal
c'est à dire que l'europe de fait a
toujours besoin aujourd'hui alors dans
vingt ans dans trente ans je n'en sais
rien je pense qu'on n'en prend pas
vraiment le chemin a toujours besoin des
états unis qui sont de plus en plus
réticents en termes de garanties de
sécurité ça c'est la réalité et stasi
qui regarde vers l'asie nous reste deux
minutes alors audacieux aux stratèges
poutine fait un tour de table boîtier ah
ben je répondu je pense tacticien titien
donc nier notre vidéo des sinistrés en
deux mots s'il avait été stratège il
aurait fait de la russie en 22 ans avec
les richesses qu'elle a un pays certes
autoritaire mais où les gens vivent à
peu près correctement là on l'a dit avec
le co vide il perd il risque de perdre
encore 1 million de citoyens avec une
stratégie pareil pardonnez moi mais pour
quelqu'un qui veut la puissance et la
magnificence de la russie à cette pas
formidable pascal boniface audacieux aux
stratèges uni
dans la mesure où avec des arguments
très faible ils arrivèrent les positions
stratégiques très forte d'ensemble de le
monde nico est interne à la rappeler et
en même temps là où je rejoins mon
interlocuteur c'est que en vingt ans il
ne s'est pas débarrassé de la dépendance
russe aux exportations de gaz et de
pétrole et donc il n'a pas réformer
l'économie qui aurait pu donner une
assise tout à fait différente nicolas
tenzer audace et aux stratèges
certainement pas stratège et profitant
de manière absolument extraordinaire de
la faiblesse et de l'absence de
stratégie des autres et puis je crois
qu'il faut pas l'oublier non plus aussi
de plus en plus profondément idéologues
et je crois que la composante
idéologiques de l'action de poutine de
destruction des libertés du monde libre
des principes sur lesquels le monde
sensé ou être fondées je crois que c'est
aussi une des caractéristiques de ce
régime et c'est ça qui le rend beaucoup
plus dangereux que n'importe quel autre
régime précisément parce que cette
idéologie de destruction est beaucoup
moins visible que ne pouvait l'être par
exemple idéologie communiste qu'elle
soit chinoise ou russe merci beaucoup à
nicolas tenzer merci à vous pascal
boniface merci gauthier et puis merci
bien sûr un gulliver crack était avec
nous à l ena volochine qui étaient avec
nous donc du kazakhstan merci à vous
tous suivi reste avec nous sur france 24
[Musique]